[Musique]
je suis d'origine cantonais le sud de la
Chine
les Marseillais chinois et un peu de
temps après s'unir c'était la guerre
sino-japonaise et pour fuir la guerre ma
famille a quitté le canton et on est
arrivé à Saigon Sud vernam maintenant on
appelle hoching après le bac je suis
allé à Formose pour suivre mes études
universitaires et je suis venu en France
puisque ma mère a connu mon beau-père
qui est d'origine française en arrivant
en France je suis une école des travels
publics je suis diplômé Ingénieur des
travaux publics
j'ai commencé à travailler à Paris dans
un bureau privé ensuite j'ai travaillé à
un moment donné aussi dans
l'administration et après je devenais
restaurateur parce que d'abord j'aime
bien manger ce gourmand
j'ai eu une belle famille qui d'origine
restaurateur
et puis ma foi ça m'a plu
[Musique]
ou le menu est destiné à une sorte
clientèle chinoise puisque nous avons à
peu près 200 plats les Chinois ont
l'habitude d'avoir beaucoup de choix des
variétés des choses il faut comprendre
les coutumes asiatiques
il mange à toute heure ils vont
plusieurs fois par jour au restaurant
c'est à dire quand ils ont faim ils
peuvent entrer dans un restaurant manger
une soupe ou un plat ou un dessert même
les restaurants dans ce quartier chinois
beaucoup qui démarre à 9h du matin donc
pour le petit déjeuner
et
sans arrêt à toute heure jusqu'à
vraiment deux heures du matin pour le
souper
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un supermarché où on
vienne chercher tous les produits les
produits
exotiques ou alors les produits déjà
cuisinés moi-même je viens
approvisionner ici pour mon restaurant
et pour ma consommation personnelle
également il y a beaucoup de choix on
trouve beaucoup de produits médicinales
qui font des hydratés des décors
d'arbres les herbes
les carpes dont les asiatiques adorent
ça parce que c'est très vivant les
cartes vit très longtemps même une cape
quand on coupe la tête elle dit quoi
toujours
nous avons trois statuettes présents
avec la part de blanche pour la
longévité
ça c'est la réussite et le bonheur quand
on a beaucoup d'enfants pour un chinois
c'est du bonheur nous avons trouvé les
instruments qu'on met dans son hôtel
pour
commémorer les morts les ancêtres
il y a des revues
de ces journaux chinois c'est que
souvent il y a des traductions de deux
traits des lois français qui permet les
gens de savoir comment on demande une
permis de travail comment on peut louer
une maison et il y a des encades
publicité pour qu'on recherche un
travail un logement
et puis annonce de ouverture d'un
magasin tout ceci est très pratique
c'est très bien fait
nous sommes dans une association et qui
croupe tous les ressortissants d'origine
asiatique et qui sont venus de
l'Indochine German Cambodge Larousse et
il se trouve ensemble pour former une
association au service de tous ces
gens-là qui ont des problèmes
certainement à tout pointu je vais vous
montrer un petit peu de tout ça par
exemple là ils ont organisé des cours
des cours enseignés de chinois et le
français surtout gratuitement pour les
asiatiques ou autrement qui viennent
apprendre le français et en même temps
aussi le chinois
perfectionner notre langage pour ne pas
oublier notre culture
à force de parler français à l'école on
commence à oublier le chinois ça c'est
un très grave problème pour nos parents
parce que les parents parlaient pas
français et parfois pour se communiquer
avec eux on a des problèmes
[Musique]
vous faites partie de cette association
j'ai pas eu beaucoup de temps de de
donner un coup de main mais un soutien
moral certainement
à Paris je m'attache tellement que de
vivre dans un autre pays pour moi c'est
plutôt
étrange et
manque l'habitude que Paris je prends
comme chez moi
vraiment parisien peut-être plus que les
Parisiens d'ici
[Musique]
du peuple chinois depuis longtemps on a
pratiqué les traditionnelles depuis
mille milliers d'années mais on a nommé
ce nom-là c'est depuis 3 ans seulement
dynastie
[Musique]
il faut concentrer l'esprit
mais continuez comme la terre qui tourne
sans cesser sans arrêter
[Musique]
et vous avez pratiqué vous-même moi je
suis un peu paressé sur le port je
pratique le sport c'est chose là
peut-être un peu plus tard quand on sera
un peu plus âgé oui ma femme est
d'origine polonaise m'ont donné je
travaillais dans l'administration et par
une réception je suis invitée
par la suite on se fréquente et voilà
dans le fond nous trouvons de tout dans
ce magasin là et plein de légumes
exotiques des fines herbes les fruits
frais qu'on va rarement jusque là à
Paris mais spécialement dans ce magasin
on peut taper les marchandises on peut
le trier on peut le choisir c'est
magnifique
psychologiquement les gens adorent ça
c'est très commerçant
dans beaucoup de magasins on n'a pas
droit d'y toucher on vous fait de
reproches ici vous avez tout à fait la
liberté de champ magnifique
[Musique]
un des plus grands attractions des
asiatiques qui vit en France évidemment
c'est la vidéo puisque on trouve
beaucoup d'histoires d'amour de karaté
en film plusieurs épisodes les Chinois
viennent chercher louer et ils
reprennent ces autres tranquillement
quand ils ont de temps libre ils vont
regarder tous une série de films une
après l'autre il se suit patiente à tel
point que certains soirs ont lobby de
dormir les films ne plus demander plus
répandues actuellement c'est un film de
kung-fu où il y a de distribution
terrible les gens viennent chercher ils
font la queue pour l'avoir et on vient
de me dire que ces films là pour
l'instant sont destinés ou asiatique
mais bientôt il y aura une traduction
sous-titrage en français donc pour Paris
ils peuvent penser un certain temps
venir chercher tous ces films chinois
aussi et de le regarder
[Musique]
nous avons choisi ici pour faire ce
poème de nostalgie ici la bagotte
c'est un poème de nostalgie qu'on a pris
en tant que à l'école je pense tous les
gosses Chinois connaissent ce poème là
la nostalgie pour les Chinois c'est
quelque chose de triste de regrettable
parce que on est loin du pays mais on
aimerait bien de retrouver dans ces
conditions là des mêmes souvenirs le bon
souvenir qu'on a eu le même décor
des mêmes amis et on regrette qu'il ne
soit pas là on se dit s'ils étaient là
si le décor était même que j'ai connu à
ce moment là on a une idée plus que
parfait de bons souvenirs à pas qu'on
veut bien qu'il soit là
[Musique]
c'est un poème
qu'on veut dire devant le lit au clair
de la lune
qui vous fait croire qu'il y a plein de
neige par terre
on monte la tête pour regarder la lune
la même lune nous faire penser au pays
natal quand on pèse la tête finalement
vous vous sentez plus français ou plus
chinois
les deux vraiment les deux c'est mon
pays adoptif
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]